[ __ ] mesdames messieurs maintenant
j'accueille quelqu'un qui depuis quinze
ans additionne les tubes et puis
aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit que tout ça
baisse ça a été que des bonnes chansons
et ça finit par faire un répertoire de
qualité
j'accueille marc lavoine comment ça va
joue bien je vais les michèle bernier
oui je laissais michèle bernier pardon
renaud muselier
bonjour idar 10 et la la la la france
entière bonsoir je dis bon soir à la
france
bon alors marc lavoine thierry ardisson
ouais alors je lui ai montré à la caméra
septième du manga son septième album et
il s'appelle septième ciel à malin il ya
une chanson là dedans qu'on entend tout
seul la journée ça s'appelle est
drôlement bien
ouais c'est très bien vous connaissez
cette chanson est allé bien trop façon
il va la changer et oui elle est
vachement bien cette chanson ça tombe
bien la tournesol caracol machin c'est
sûr timmy c'est sympa mais qui valent à
chanter c'est pour ça qu'il traîne
trylive à la chancellerie
c'est un mollet mais c'est julie qui me
de quoi vous parlez
red herring est l'un pkra cole tournage
il a passé du bon cadeau c'est ce que
c'est maintenant une cagole non une
cagole à marseille c'est une [ __ ]
indiqué c'est la femme du cas excellent
cocktail jours à marseille n'a fait
qu'aggraver
voilà bon alors septième ciel septième
album doo steve zahn et composé six ça
c'est nouveau
avant j'étais dans les paroles sur vos
albums et vous cliquez vite et fort rare
que vous écriviez les musiques
oui ça oui parce qu'avant c'est fabrice
aboulker qui faisait la partie des
musiques il les faisait mieux que
j'imaginais pouvoir le faire moi même
et puis là bas tournesol la musique
c'est vous par exemple pas mal oui je
les cocons poser ses crayons macario
mène des chansons étions les tribunes
avec quelqu'un sinon je vais l'eau ça
valorise pas mon travail est quelqu'un
qui fort dans la musique déjà
ouais ça valorise le travail donc ça
nous engage à continuer alors maintenant
on va vous faire une petite
vous aurez un blind test à la fin de
l'émission si vous chanterez les
tournesols ça nous fera plaisir